gonna work with me
first time no no no long time ago
different life now you come back yes I'm
looking to something you can find
whatever you wish important about a man
who kidnapped little girl from her
American mother would look be looking
for such a time will be there Jess for
you men like him with big baby Robert
I'm the only friend
it's great you helping all these random
people and everything
but stay off the radar something happens
to one of ours
so I'm obligated to look into it about
you every time
oh I am just like you're dead yeah
what's the matter
[Music]
they knew the floor she was off
we're tying up loose ends exactly
partner for seven years let's mistake to
go to war with him they're going to war
with me
whoever did this of all chart skill sets
if at the agency family busy start right
very good
well not one one goat
they killed my friends
so I'm gonna kill each and every one of
them and then I'll they disappoint me is
that only I get to do it once
senior care and all those books around I
figured you for some kind of teacher
from a high level paid from the assassin
you